[Music]
tonight on Kitchen Nightmares Gordon
hits the Big Apple I'm here on the floor
New York Stock Exchange about to ring
the opening bell on a serious mission to
turn around Black Pearl Restaurant and
when the bell
rings Gordon is in for his toughest
fight yet I'm ready I suppose you
actually don't give a [__] a Lobster
Shack with three feuding owners you get
mad at these two yeah one owner who was
thrown in the towel you're the weakest
link in the chain another owner who is
fed up with his Partners I get mad at
them cuz I don't think they're doing
what they need to do and we feel exactly
the same about him and a third owner who
can't see eye to eye with anyone this R
has every chance of succeeding you're
wrong the great Gordon Ramsey is wrong
especially Gordon you're big sad fake
can Gordon get through to these three
owners and turn the Black Pearl around
you all look so so cool as if you don't
give a [__] it's disgusting or is this
place doomed by its ineffective
three-headed monster why don't you call
it so I know what it is I have called it
I've called it do times incredible this
is a New York City battle you don't want
to miss I've never met an individual
that's so full of [__] in all my life
how Gordy how tell me Gord yeah you want
to disrespect me I can disrespect you
too tonight it's Mayhem in Manhattan
you're so full of [__] [__] you'd
make a great politician you know that my
advice would be for you to disappear and
the sooner the
[Music]
[Applause]
better New York City restaurant capital
of the world World home to thousands of
restaurants vying to be the Crown Jewel
of the city right this we l the Black
Pearl just being
one started by two friends as a small
downtown Lobster Shack they moved to
Midtown added a third partner and hope
to become the premier Lobster restaurant
in Manhattan I suggested to Brian that
we put an ad in the paper to find uh an
investor since we didn't want to spend
any of our own money ordering two hot
lobser rolls I met Greg and thought that
he would be a perfect match gentlemen
fish and chips it was David's concept
and um I thought the concept was really
very good and I thought would make some
pretty good money did we get that 2500
cuz I'm about 4 grand short of payroll
the problem started when we started to
run low on money it became very
frustrating around here Brian and Greg
and I stopped speaking we would try to
communicate by email text messaging and
everybody got nervous and frustrated
this place is a nightmare for the lack
of management we don't have one void
well I just asked Brian and he's like
yeah well you guys can figure it out we
always figure it out well I know cuz
they don't tell us what to do I think
Brian's more of a silent partner if he
had a choice he'd probably just not have
to work here at all this table had a
hair in their fries I don't want to deal
with this you deal with it Greg is the
hardest working owner but he doesn't
make a decision who the [__] put these
letters on here I couldn't tell you out
of the three owners I like David the
least because his ego tends to get in
the way of a healthy atmosphere don't
touch the tickets Please the main
problem with the black pearl is these
guys are really stubborn and if Gordon
Ramsey can help us all kind of mesh
together then this place can be
phenomenal New York City one of the most
difficult places ever to open a restant
I opened mine 14 months ago and I've
been busting my balls ever since I'm
dying to see how the Black Pearl are
doing
right the black PE there you
go hi hello how you doing good and you
are Nigel Nigel my name is stepen St how
are you we here at the black PE
desperately need Gordon's help we need
him to come in and kind of whip all of
the owners into shape how's business
could be better but with three owners
and all three of them being over the
business they must be here what three or
four times a week each together no
they're never here together no they're
never here together no
is that one of the owners yes it is
exellent hi what's your name David
Leonard David Gordon nice to see you you
are one of the three owners one of the
three owners and are you hands on or
hands off hands on hands on and how many
days a week are you here I do three or
four three or four okay good I'm going
to grab a quick bite to eat maybe start
off with a little hole of chowa and then
maybe have a chat after I'll be around
when I walked in and first met Gordon I
thought he seemed a bit confront ation
that was not very pleasant but otherwise
I really had no impression of them I'll
be back with some water for you my name
is Step so if you need anything just let
me know thank you I like your enthusiasm
by the way thank
you what a weird bar and when you look
at the bizarre concoction of the
Interior it does confirm that three
different people the owners of course
decorated it all right wow that was
quick now how many's in the kitchen how
many people yeah or three three there
you go well thank you that smells lovely
did you need more time to look at the
menu or um no I'll order no actually you
know that um um I'll go for a uh musle
Bangkok all right a mac and cheese
lobster please and then I'll finish with
the lobster roll if you're looking for
the most popular one it would be the
Maine and the Connecticut you know what
bring me the three of them all three all
right we'll do thank you so much my name
is stepen so if you need anything just
let me know no you just making sure if
you need anything just yell if
anything's bad I didn't do it though so
I don't want to
know what was your name Michael no what
your name H very
funny you're a kider
when Chef Ramsey joked around with me I
think it added that personal spark of oh
you know Chef Ramsey isn't this evil
devil that everybody sees him as M
bangok first course okay then a lobster
mac and cheese after that okay and he
has a chowder right
now little bit watery for CH
huh what a
[Music]
shame hello Chef how are you oh fa thank
you you you're musles Bangkok I'm Greg
one the owners one of the owners I'm not
one I'm not the chef trust me you don't
want eat my food way come from nice to
meet you nice to meet you too sir so
there's one more owner to come yes Brian
so David Brian and Greg okay great
lovely right
confusing thank you go
[Music]
ahead burn your mouth off my
God [__] me that's hot lobster mac and
cheese excellent lobster mac and cheese
wow thank you speak of the devil and
I'll let you enjoy how are you nice to
meet you I'm good yourself yeah very
well indeed thank you yes how did three
of you come to run a rest up originally
David and I had the place uh down on
Evan away and then we decided to get out
of there fascinating okay I'm going to
tuck into my uh mac and cheese with
lobster okay thank
you gets more and more
complicated I'm figing we send out all
three lobster rolls on separate plates
dressed just like they would be yeah
yeah yeah so far he doesn't like much
what do you mean food wise the muscles
can't taste of muscles cuz of stupid Tha
Curry Bangkok broth mac and cheese it's
chewy and rich and the Chow at watery
it's not how a seafood restant should
run this is not going to be a good
[Laughter]
thing thank you all right this is the
Connecticut or the hot lobster roll okay
new this is the main lobster roll main
lobster roll whoops Connecticut Main
don't worry about that and this is the
New York City lobster roll New York City
Connecticut Main gotcha all righty
that's great thank you right let's start
off with CT drawn
butter
horrible soaking wet bread it's like
eating a [__] wet diaper so sorry
Connecticut but I am moving
on lobst is not
seasoned plan what a shame all right so
what what did you think of the main
pretty piss po to be honest I'm going to
stop there thank you
Steven what's up well he likes Steven
yeah that's all I know that's his boy is
he still here yeah he's still upstairs
what's he doing he's eating he had three
lobster rolls three different kinds he
had mac and cheese he had um Bangkok
David wants to know is he paying for
this you should definitely give yeah
give him a check I can see that that'll
be fun
huh
after tasting the supposedly best food
on the menu how are you Gordon gathers
the three owners and head chef Bill who
oversees the food I do the award-winning
lobster roll bread soggy Lobster Bland
do you not SE it salt pepper when you
bind it with mayonnaise no no why not
well we get most of our recipes and
ideas from Main and it's not the way
it's done they have salt in Maine i'
I've lived in Maine for 3 months I know
it very well Chef Ramsey didn't like our
lobster roll he said he's lived in Maine
for 3 months but if he'd lived in Maine
for 3 months he'd know that a lobster
roll is exactly the way we make it I'm
really nervous now I've never known a
chef that's not allowed to season his
food is this man your Chef or is he your
puppet no he's my chef David has this
tone of being condescending
and knowing it all how much debt have we
gotten over the house4 mil yeah yeah who
has the final say if one of us presents
an idea we vote on it and we decide
whether we want to go forward with it or
not is hard running a business with
three Partners it's hard for us yeah
when was the last time all three of you
sat down we have not we have not done so
okay I don't
feel that any of you are committed to
making this work have we fallen out oh
yeah a couple of three times yeah so
that's why we don't meet yeah okay who
fell out with who oh I get mad at them
why uh cuz I don't think they're doing
what they need to do and we feel exactly
the same about him of course
yeah I felt that Gordon was right about
many things but I think he jumped to
conclusions and that we are not
committed to Black Pearl a restaurant
run by three passionate owners no chance
Brian he works two days a week David
well I don't trust in one little inch
and as for Greg well he's pissed off
with both of them basically in a
nutshell sleepy Dopey and grumpy who am
I snow [__]
white coming up Gordon confirms that
three is definitely a crowd
unfortunately the appendix out all three
of you is Brian we don't need him you
get to go home really yeah but two
doesn't prove to be much better we have
several brains in here where the [__] is
this why don't you call it so I know
what it is I have called it I called it
it does in time and there is definitely
one who stands out you know what I've
just discovered you're so full of
[__] [__] you'd make a great
politician and later Gordon discovers
the black Pearl's little secret they
look Canadian L to me yeah these are
Canadian you [__] amazing me the
awardwinning main lobster rooll is
Canadian that's all coming up on Kitchen
Nightmares after a frustrating
conversation with the owners Chef Ramsey
decides to take a look at how the Black
Pearl operates during a dinner service
especially on a night that all three
owners are there Hi how are you recomend
the Chow's good
Atari it's really good I promise
ordering two hot lobster rolls where's
that FIS Bill coming right now David I
got a crab cake it's getting cold two
lobster rolls and a fried shrimp to be
the bite the shrimp rolls not ready yet
what happened with that I don't have a
fried french fries so when you and Brian
are here together on the same day Brian
Tes care of the we're never here
together the same you never yeah it was
weird having David in here exped cuz he
doesn't normally do that and having
someone on this side of the line that
knows what they're doing is key we have
one more crab cake no no I you sold the
last one oh that's it we don't have
it
that's
R hey how you guys doing I believe this
may be
R what's song undercooked undercooked
that way we're deep fat frying it this
can't be normal they surely to shed I
need to order of fried shrimp this one
was undercooked what are you kidding me
David's lack of experience on the pass
is resulting in lack of quality control
they wanted these two well done zap them
un [__] believable zap what's that
four fuckups already with them I think
it was a competition amongst the three
owners to try and prove to Chef Ramsey
that they knew what they were doing and
I felt Greg kind of felt out of his
element cuz he's normally in the kitchen
I'll take this back and we'll do
something about the muses we got sand in
the muscles there supposed to be s in
the humor that's why they get a [__]
BR I don't know guys so people don't
know what the [__] they're ordering what
are they ordering David definitely a
know-it-all and he can be a little rude
what table is that table eight thank
you hi you had the uh
clanic and there was a problem with the
muscles or the Steamers both they're
terribly sand yeah there should be sand
there often is and that's why you have
the broth to dip them in what would you
like instead of those uh nothing in fact
I'll just eat the lobster I'm fine okay
it'll be right
out reprimanded I do not think that Chef
Ramsey likes David because Chef Ramsey
has a [__]
detector and David could be full of it
sometimes what happed thanks CHF no
they're done they're done yeah they just
didn't like it Jesus Christ that's the
funniest fishing chips I've ever seen in
my life you know that what happened can
I just smell inside there will you
please Phil 2
seconds to me from the what do you smell
Phil it smells old why didn't they eat
it I don't know Gordon yeah did you ever
ask yourself that question I don't I
that question all the time I suppose you
actually don't give a [__] you know that
I do give a [__] and you know I give a
[__] you seem a very relaxed man with
your rest what do you want me to do I
disagree it doesn't smell bad to me the
fish I just given a piece of your Chef
yeah the piece was stinking it wasn't
stinking you're blind my friend no if
you're not blind you're [__] clueless
you know
that now the owner said it's not
stinking it fragrant fresh and perfect
that's why it came back right massage
his
ego concerned about the quality control
of the food yeah show me around and the
true truthfulness of the owner Gordon
wants to do a little investigating
they're all from Maine these are uh
Maine some from Canada they look
Canadian lobsters to me yeah these are
Canadian so the Canadian lobsters they
always a lot cheaper I use the Canadian
lobsters for raviolis and tagat Tellis
and spaghetti but they're not main
[Music]
lobsters after a dis appointing dinner
service comes to an end Gordon is ready
to share some of his initial
observations tough day today and I'm um
I'm deeply concerned I see a ship here
that is rudderless and maybe that was
the first time that all three of you
were working inside this restaurant in a
long time tonight showed when was the
last time you expedited all the time I'm
back there you were not you're not
really back there as much as you were
back there tonight no i' never because
it's never been that we've never had the
whole line line up the whole line with
tickets ever David can you stop being a
slippery eel for 15 minutes in front of
your team and answer the [__] truth
Gordon the [__] truth is that I'm
back there when it's busy every [__]
night that I work I think a lot of what
Chef Ramsey's had to say about David was
fairly true of I don't believe that
David shows that he cares okay I've I've
seen enough today I've got to go and
start really seriously [__]
understanding you know how to get a
direction within this
restaurant I'll see you first thing in
the morning good night uh David yeah you
tell me about the passion with the main
lobster are you aware that the lobsters
in your fridge are
Canadian same water as North Atlantic
Waters you're telling me now Canadian
Lobster half the price of a main lobster
is the same taste and flavor there's a
big
difference I can't get main lobsters
that's right so they get them from can
I'm using Canadian lobsters that's right
that's what they do but but I don't
advertise them as Maine tell me is it a
different animal Maine mhm is a Canadian
lobster for you marus americanas same
animal right holy [__] I'm asking you a
question what you're trying to dictate
to me is that you're selling main
lobster they're not from Main oh it
comes from the same
vendor holy [__] the awardwinning main
lobster role is
Canadian he was wrong about the lobster
issues it pissed me off I thought that
was was a bit unfair for him to take
that stand especially since he was
incorrect about it I will see you in the
morning good night good
night that was fun
incredible it's a new day and Gordon has
organized a staff meeting how are we
good a rarity here at Black Pearl as
there have not been any meetings in the
last 7 months okay a quick exercise so I
want to find out how you you feel we're
going to write anonymous questions when
you write make sure you put the name you
want the question to at the top of it
fold it up and put it straight in the PO
okay Greg how come you waffle with your
answers basically I try to keep
everybody happy because otherwise I
wouldn't have a staff and that's why I
sometimes waffle and go back and forth
but if you had a a little bit stricter
Philosophy for I could definitely be
stricter oh yeah I could definitely be
stricter thanks for being honest okay
David why haven't we got aprons they
know where the aprons are they just
don't choose to wear them but why can't
you say it's policy to be in an apron
cat it's policy for you not to have a
drink here after your shift but you
often
do why can't you ask my question without
a question I did answer your
question it did that is quintessential
David he'll answer you with the question
so to communicate with him can be very
frustrating David show the girl some
respect will you You're great at beating
around the bush you know that huh in
front of everybody why can't you answer
the [__] question thought I did
answer the question rather trying to be
such a smart ass and answer question the
question do you know what I've just
discovered you're so full of [__]
[__] you'd make a great politician you
know that David has the biggest ego he's
very stubborn and obviously you're not
doing everything correct so get over
yourself and allow somebody to help you
incredible I'm [__] surprised you got
anybody working for you the last half
hour you all look so so cool as if you
don't give a [__] it's
disgusting and finally to all three
owners why don't we have one general
manager what are they crying out for
Greg crying out for Direction they need
a Rudder make it one of the three why
can't it be just one of the three owners
thank you Absol absolutely critical One
Voice One Direction so who's
[Music]
committed I believe that I'm capable of
doing it um but now I have to follow
through and do it I think Brian and
David will get on board I'm going to get
some fresh air I'll see you
later as the owners were contemplating
which one of them should be the Hands-On
manager Chef Ramsey decided to generate
some excitement for tonight's dinner
service by adding a new special okay yep
right time for a new beginning okay the
secret of this dish is the lobster
Burnes Lobster that going eat first
underneath is breadcrumbs potatoes and a
hint of Rosemary first off the membrane
and the inside of the lobster out going
serve this one open and out okay done
and have potatoes okay get the potatoes
nice and crispy yeah put our bread
crumbs in there 2/3 potato 1/3 bread
crumbs okay now they're starting to
color okay good out and lightly fried
okay line the Shell with that now I want
to see it ooze Lobster okay on and then
we'll go with our sauce absolutely
delicious and then in the salamander
okay this is a absolute pleasure to have
him in here and showing us things and we
learned a lot M
Lobster I would pay $40 for that yes
right get some Forks in let's have a
little taste a little bit of peino
lightly over the top it's delicious
I'm not blowing smoke at my ass but that
was [__] delicious it is great I'm I
don't give a
[Music]
[__] long day today I want to try
something for tonight so here's what
we're going to do I want you to run in
the place for an hour okay you expedite
and then you switch and I want to see
one person step up to the mark and take
control of the ship unfortunately the
appendix our all three of you is Brian
we don't need him he's a nice guy and
all that but nice guy don't run
restaurants okay all right thank
you David is going to be expedited for
the first hour then we're going to
switch back I have the choice of Greg or
David I would definitely prefer Greg
because I think he's a really nice
person and great to work with what's
something you good to go home really
yeah okay all
right am I out of here do you mind I I
don't I mean you don't mind that's great
is it is it all right
yeah absolutely fine don't take your
person got have a relaxed evening all
right excellent I felt a little
uncomfortable being pulled for my own
restaurant but I've get to go
home how much longer open open open open
you ready guy okay hi there welcome to
Black Pearl right this we
lose all right you guys enjoy ready to
rock thank you very much and roll the
specials for today um are on the front
left it's a a 1 and a/4 lb Lobster split
in half and and then with the Bern sauce
on top of that it's delicious I have to
say it was really good R next time you
come back would you bring me a DI soda
and mix a little bit of club soda in it
too so it's not quite so sweet here let
me uh get that out of your way you want
um these you want to keep these or take
those away okay yeah don't just put the
club soda at the end because then it
won't have the mixture you know mix it
in thank you take care now good to meet
you so I have two fish and chips table
36 oh how about I rip your [__] heart
what when David's Expediting orders
sometimes I'm a little nervous about
going into the kitchen to ask about my
tables cuz he'll just bite back at you I
I I fired this one so yep I know that's
why it's over there talk to me like I'm
a real person not like I'm an idiot DAV
I just want to remind you of this one I
wrote glutenfree I got it we
El we have several brands in here oh my
God keep an eye I'm going to go switch
with
bread switch
okay right we're halfway through service
and uh Greg's on the hot plate now I
can't wait to see what happens but
personally once a waffler always a
waffler we'll find
[Music]
out muscles Bok thank
you I can't find the Bangkok Bangkok
there they are that it is you coming or
going com me how many are you five under
what name Jackson David sometimes can uh
patronize the customers a little bit
Jackson 5 I rather have someone that's
going to be cordial about it than some
[__] that's going to patronize
everybody man you guys are
always pH this L the roll sitting here
what's it going with I didn't tell you
it was even ready it's waiting for a ro
talk to me guys let me that's what I'm
trying to say I mean just sat there
[__] going soggy standards yeah let's
start to talk to me too I'm down
here it's a blue point malpe and a
Malisa and they said they already had it
they did they did then why am I doing it
again 35 I have no clue you can use we
got food backed up now last line of
defense which tables don't like it well
it was um my table 8 and table 30 did
they fire it no okay fire it they're
waiting they already had their oysters
muscles with garlic Lobster bernet it
seems to be slower on the hot plate with
GRE the helm than
when yes it does it seems to be a little
bit slower with it
C GRE I
feel is trying his best and a bis no
Jesus Christ where the hell did that go
why don't you call it so I know what it
is what are you waiting for D oysters oh
they're coming then all right maybe
where the hell did it go I don't have a
Lobster biscuit it went out come on get
it together man making it another too
[__] [__] getting very [__] tired
getting very [__] tired of that [__]
[__] up
just when things seemed completely out
of control I don't have a lobster bis
where the hell do that go getting very
[__] tired of that [__] come on guys
Greg settled things down in the kitchen
put the old girl on the plate and get
her out of here all right thank you sir
86 it and managed to get the final few
plates out that's it start cleaning it
out breaking it up before Gordon can
turn black pearl around he needs to find
one managing owner
so he gathers the staff to make a
decision if all of you had to choose one
out the three owners to direct and to
run this place completely who would it
be write it down for
[Music]
me okay first
person
David second
vote
Greg third vote Greg
Greg four V
Greg and
finally Greg this is pretty significant
you know that guys how do you feel Greg
if you were to run this place i' I'd run
it the way I think it should be run um I
would do a lot more with the staff um
and I wouldn't have to justify myself
all the
time all three of you have fragmented
this business David isn't it best that
we listen to the team for that cry of
help rather than having to massage your
own egos I think Greg would be a perfect
General Manager David is full of [__]
I've heard him say many times that Greg
has no idea what he's doing in a
restaurant so it will be very
interesting I'd definitely like to give
it a shot for sure thank you all for
being Hest thank
you well one thing's clear that the
staff won't Greg to run this place even
David wants Greg to run it so that's
good news but I'm not 100% certain that
Greg has the Bulls to run this place
properly on the back of tonight's
performance but what I can tell you is
the business does not need
Brian in the city that never sleeps Chef
Ramsey's team worked all through the
night to transform the Black Pearl into
a Manhattan hot spot right good morning
good morning you ready yeah let's go
oh everything is uniform oh wow much
better we haven't got three different
sections with three different colors
it's not a mix and match oh those are so
cute it's vibrant classic and inviting
like it should be oh this is so
nice I love the lobster it gives us a
great boost this is a a really a real
good shot at getting this thing up and
moving the way it needs to
be DAV what do you
think column should be
yellow everything's reorganized it's you
know it's another way to do it David
please don't touch it does it Blow Me
Away
no I've got something to explain over
here something quite exciting it was
donated by the Marine ecological habitat
now I promise you you'll never find
another machine anywhere like this in
New York and David I promise you now
between you and I this is from
Maine and of course if they catch it
they eat it yes I think it's
terrific oh you got it we're going to
have all sorts of people coming in there
trying to get a lobster out of
that and people will be attracted to it
you are mine and it's going to be a lot
of fun to
watch as the staff enjoyed the new
interior Chef ramsy got set to reveal
another change looks great happy
everybody yes now we have to Market this
place yes and I can't do it without the
help of our special guest here he comes
EXC
that's right how you doing buddy
Manhattan's favorite lobster right all
we go hit Time Square and get some noise
on there we're going to hand out fliers
we're going to hand out t-shirts we're
going to shout it out okay Lou the ler
I'll see you in h Time Square in 5
minutes yes get going buddy yes and
Louie if you [__] up you're going in the
tank
[Music]
okay
please come visit us
tonight being in Time Square with Chef
Gordon Ramsey and all those people was a
terrific idea have a great day yes thank
you very much I'm your restaurant
tonight it's New York the word spreads
fast so I think people will be rolling
in tonight come visit us to the black PE
tonight going to Time Square with The
Lobster Guy and where all the tourist
are and tell him to come down eat at
your restaurant we're not going to see
any effect from that I'd be really
surprised we love you tonight
only hours before the doors open for
relaunch Chef ramsy wants to get
everyone up to speed on the new menu
okay start off from the top uh we'll go
through each and every dish and then
we'll have a little taste after it okay
okay good right two chowers yes
Manhattan clam chowder New England clam
chowder yeah the lobster roll Black
Pearl uh special and it's going to be
toasted on the inside as well okay so it
doesn't go soggy and then we go to the
Boston cream pie and a waffle sundae
it's fresh it's vibrant standards are
going to be set tonight and the
kitchen's going to be proper run okay
good let to get changed get some life
and Fs start tasting saiche majorly
trendy you taste a saich it's so good
not very
good I don't like it really those
scallops were so good oh my God this
looks like heaven I don't like that
shrimp thing either that's amazing a and
that's good too what kind of fish isn't
codfish didn't I don't really like
that coming up we had a great call SL
dve continues his tiate against Gordon
that's ridiculous and note to Greg
you're now running this place our puppet
dictator Greg tries to handle the
restaurant on his own so she wants to
sell give s just tell me that H oh my
god do Brian and David help out service
sucks here got a gun and has Gordon this
is real for me finally been pushed too
far you're not passionate [__] you
Gordon you're ungrateful so what you're
soulless you want to disrespect me I can
disrespect you you're not not going to
believe what happens you're wrong the
great Gordon Ramsey is wrong that's all
coming up on Kitchen
Nightmares with relaunch night upon them
Gordon gathers the owners to implement
his biggest change when you think back
to the beginning of the week it's been a
bit sort of tempestuous but we did come
to a consensus on who should be running
this restaurant this is a document
basically outlining that all three of
you are happy for Greg to be running
this black Pearl could you just read out
for me we the partners David Leonard
Greg Ryan and Brian Woods agree to name
Greg Ryan as the managing partner of the
Black Pearl at which time decisions
involving bigger issues arise Greg must
call a meeting to present the proposed
changes to all of the owners a majority
rule will determine whether or not the
proposed changes should be made that's
it I who would like to sign first my
name's
first I'll sign first I don't know if I
have more faith in Greg so if Greg
succeeds that'll be great wonderful
there you go so you're now running this
place I am yeah good David Brian tonight
you're coming as guest all right 630 T
was booked I'll see you later beautiful
thank you now get the [__] out of it I
definitely feel that I'm in control now
U and that I'm going to run the business
the way I think the business needs to be
run all right guys we're going to have a
big night tonight we have a beautiful
new restaurant we have wonderful new
menu and we're going to have a lot of
people in tonight and that's the best
thing that can happen here anyway so
please everybody have a great time do a
good job and we're going to going to be
great okay thank
[Music]
you party five part five I just we
guys with the lobster B all
righty medium rare with cheese make sure
the waiters get the customers up to have
a little go of pulling the lobsters out
oh yeah I will and then we'll let you
have that yes make sure make sure we get
the customers up to play Lobster Roma we
are encouraging customers to try for a
lobster cuz if you catch one we steam it
for you and it's
free here we go first course wi clam
chowder field greens and tuna
saiche it's going to be a big night
tonight and this is Greg's chance now to
step up to the mark and prove to him and
his two partners that he's capable of
running this business we got a flip
tables we're going to be under a lot of
pressure and more importantly the
kitchen has a menu streamlined they can
push out quickly only time will tell
grilled swordfish in a uh
and a burger medium and medium rare is a
swordfish you took the wrong table what'
I take where' it Go Gordon introduce you
to my closest friends in the world are
you as stubborn as this one uh
yes Gord I'm a guest sorry excuse me yes
I welcome come in come out the cold
please we got a Hostess over here please
as customers roll in the kitchen is
about to be slammed with orders and Greg
and his kitchen staff are about to face
their first big task I need a chicken a
slider of bernes and of two fries also
another fish soup another Burger Medium
you're killing me Chef you're killing me
the lantern this things are terrible
especially put candles three chickens
four sword thank you table one have sub
salad they got the table table one so
what do they want instead of fries she
wanted salad have it I first saw the
Tank part and I said we got us a [__]
Lobster tank only one in New York what
does that tell you what can we do
anything got a gun what's the on table
27 I put in the pearls and appetizer and
I did not fire their Entre yet and
they're getting their Entre [__] come on
hold on this is all3 B3 right here yeah
that's what I'm trying to do service
sucks here kitchen must be [__]
buried I need three New England pant I
got grilled swordfish two soups two
Seafood casseres I can't cook for two
people who call in order I don't give a
[__] just make it son fcking
[__] I'll take this back and I'll see
what we can do about that all right
34 said he got a New England clam sh
give me a break I need a Manhattan clam
I mean a New England clam shter now jeez
tonight has been like a cluster [__]
again the kitchen got backed up it took
forever for all of our food to come out
come on Greg we got to run it we're
falling behind in there come on it's
ridiculous that Lobster Sal as me sat
down there for [__] 20 minutes what's
going on you're supposed to go out with
this table right here the uh C very
different from ours we had a great C we
had a great we can go back on that
that's ridiculous Greg you told me 33
for the fishion chips I did not tell you
33 I didn't tell you anything oh my God
you got a pen I got to rent this down
note to Greg our puppet dictator so she
wants a salad give her a salad that's
all just tell me
that I ordered a medium
rare yeah thank you where'd you go what
do you need medium rare [__] uh what if
she want this medium where the [__] is
sick you guys why you call it so I know
what it is I've called it I've called it
a dozen times I got grilled swordfish
two soups a sirloin burger two lobster
rolls how many times can I call
[Music]
it all right I need table 20 I need
table one I I need Table 9 I got [__]
getting cold it's been a chaotic evening
right there right there it's going out
the door right now and the kitchen has
been on the brink of disaster come on
you guys you got to set your kitchen too
you can't do it all for you right but
Greg has not given up get him organized
and and neither has his staff I need
three of these right off the bat just
stack them up there I'm going to 36 I'll
be back excuse me this the blueberry
crumble people okay what's the feedback
from the T everyone really likes the
food even though it's taken a while to
get there without having David or Brian
around it was actually all right it was
pretty good the staff worked very well
together and so that made me feel good
all night long the lobster was really
good nice buttery you might have to do
another waffle thing yeah I could have
about four more waffles
all right got one ticket left Greg's
doing really good he's making decisions
like right and left and that's a big
change High Five Guys I just can't wait
to see what's going to happen 2 3 months
from now after Chef Ramsey has
left after a tough relaunch dinner
Gordon gathers David Brian and Greg to
give his final words of advice tonight
you stood on that hot plate and you
busted your ass off all night night long
mate you've got a big heart [__] me if
you got passion thank you but whilst
you've got the hunger and the passion I
don't think your two partners actually
give a
dam you are an honest individual you're
here two days a week but you don't put
the effort
in you amaze me what because all week
long face to face you [__] pretend to
care oh [__] Gordon come on you don't
give to [__] about this place really
you're not passionate about running a
restaurant really you're just abusing it
and using it what what what what did I
do I've never met an individual that's
so full of [__] in all my life how have
I been lying to you Gordy how tell me
Gordy yeah how you want to disrespect me
I can disrespect you too but tell me how
tell me tell me how I I'm not disrespect
you I'm telling you the truth you're
disrespect me because you don't know the
truth you're just massaging your [__]
ego Gord [__] what do you mean
[__] not true from the first minute
you walked in this [__] door standing
there with your big long coat and your
[__] sunglasses looking like proud
[__] that was it first
impressions then you start debating
lobsters cuz you think you're some
smartass on the back of a few [__]
[__] dive books are you aware that the
lobsters in your fridge are Canadian
marus americanas same animal right
humanus americanus my
assos with 21 restaurants under my belt
I work my [__] ass off so what so
what and I never take anything for
granted fascinating Gordon you treat the
staff like [__] you amaze me never did
that excuse me never cat it's policy for
you not to have a drink here after your
shift but you often do never you can't
even be honest with yourself let alone
me mate you've been exposed oh yeah
Expos you're a hypocrite is that right
absolutely yeah for you it's about a
[__] TV show this man it's about a
restaurant [__] the TV David and I mean
[__] it this is real for me and for you
it's an image I disagree with you on
almost everything you said you do yeah I
do why' you disagree cuz you're wrong
the great Gordon Ramy is
wrong you're a sad
[__] my advice is for him to get his
Partners get your money out yeah and
disappear all right well my advice would
be for you to disappear and the sooner
the pet
you don't get it do you [__] you Gordon
of course I get it this R has every
chance of succeeding but not why you are
in
it because you're not passionate you're
soulless say what you like let me get
out of here you're
ungrateful and you know what really
hurts the amount of effort that's gone
into it despite what a prick you've been
to me I'm still grateful that you were
here here I love what you've done I
think that the menu is brilliant you
like it I don't like it I don't really
like the I don't like that shrimp thing
either it's what happens when I've gone
we had a great call slop had a great
call slop we can go back on that that's
ridiculous the minute I'm out that door
you'll slip back into I'll tell you what
I'll tell you why don't you come back in
and you know I'm sure you will and see
how it goes yeah time will tell I guess
it
will thanks again
Gordon good night goodbye good
[Music]
night that's tough I mean really tough
and personally I've got mixed feelings
about this week because I so want this
to succeed for Greg because he's got the
determination the guts to make it work
but on the other hand David well I think
he's just open a restaurant because he
wants to make a quick buck and that is
not the reason to open a restaurant that
man has no passion
tough tonight on Kitchen Nightmares you
can't create jack [__] from here Chef
Ramsey goes head-to-head with Long
Island's most arrogant Chef I'm very
excited to show Chef Ramsey what I can
do there will be no Faults in what I
produce him whose business is clearly
dying there will be plenty of open
tables believe me no happy hour here is
he sleeping over
there just an early bird special I feel
like I'm in Florida his girlfriend not
only supports him fire 14 her parents
have put their life savings into the
restaurant as well for my home my
retirement and everything else on the
line with this young man but this guy
doesn't think he's doing anything wrong
oh my God how can respect food if he
cooking this [__] all it's my restaurant
my rules and that should be the bot can
Gordon get through to him I wish you got
your ass kicked in a [__] kitchen you
should be ashamed he can bust my balls
but the name on the awning is troby anos
it's not Ransom before he not only
bankrupts himself you sank half a
million dollars into this [__] but his
girlfriend's family as well we're
screwed we should have never did this
one thing's for sure there's a shocking
conclusion that will change this family
forever I am out of it I don't know what
to do I'm going to [__] knock
somebody
out Great Neck New York is an upscale
community on the North Shore of Long
Island where competition among Italian
restaurants is fierce troianos has been
struggling to survive for the past 3
years owned by Anthony trobiano and his
girlfriend's parents they are now just
months away from losing
[Music]
everything my desire to own a restaurant
basically started right after culinary
school uh working for other people look
at that huh and then I said to myself
why am I busting my ass for everybody
when I could be doing it for myself yeah
Joe put a steak knife on there Anthony
came to me one day and says this place
is available you want to buy it I don't
know if it took balls or I was just
playing stupid doing it they go right
over me and ask him having a business
together you know you see too much
you're together too much there's
resentment because of it appetizers they
go out one minute I heard you me and an
been together for 6 years we used to
never fight ever I thought he was like
the best person in the world and then we
got here I'm like who am I going out
with I want a whole new [__] slip you
should have two when it comes down to
running the business it's really Anthony
runs it hey change the [__] ticket
bro come on [__] kidding it's my
restaurant my rules and that should be
the bottom line fire 14 at the beginning
troianos took off we didn't maintain the
food coming out fast enough with quality
and from there our business decreased
there will be plenty of open tables
believe
me the O bir special was my idea any
place you like it's bringing in people
to keep the boat afloat how we doing
folks everything all right forget about
it I feel like I'm in Florida it's
crazy I'm working killing myself to pay
bills I don't want to live like this I
don't I don't really want to live this
way anymore it's depressing I put my
parents into this position they were
finally getting comfortable and now they
have no choice but to work or they're
going to lose everything Anthony he's
only my daughter's boyfriend I put my
faith I put my home my retirement my
wife's well-being everything else on the
line with this young man at the end of
the day you know it is my name on the
awning to think that my name is going
down as well as the restaurant that
would definitely be disappointing you
guys have to run more food okay we are
more the last 3 years have been rough by
this time in my life I thought we would
have been married had kids already if we
don't get Chef Ramsey's help there's no
other options for
us okay here we are oh [__] it's for
sale no that's an early bird dinner menu
1495 [__] me stupid of the sub shop
right
tranos here we
are hello hi there how are you how are
you Gordon please first name is Joe Joe
good to see you very nice to meet you
Chef likewise good to see you too Pat
nice to see you when Chef Ramsey came
through that door I thought it was a
blessing I think hopefully he'll put us
straight so uh who came up with a bright
idea of opening a
restaurant you've bought a restaurant
with your future father-in-law it was
just an exciting thing you know you're
able to purchase a restaurant as a dream
of mine how old are you not 28 29 mhm so
you're were 25 when you opened it mhm
which is [__] young to open a
restaurant sure y yeah felt I was ready
ambitious you know and have you trained
in Italian restaurants no have
not I felt I knew everything I still do
are you that arrogant
possibly I wouldn't open a [__]
Italian restaurant without working in
one I definitely think everything needs
to to hear that he's arrogant because I
say to him sometimes and he takes it as
oh yeah you know you don't know what
you're talking about I'm do smacked
that's a young man at the age of 25
would manipulate his future
father-in-law to open an Italian
restaurant having never worked in a
[__] Italian restaurant that doesn't
make sense no offense I didn't pin him
down and handcuff him and said you I
need your house to put the restaurant
you've got the house
now Chef Ramsey was you know making me
feel like it's my fault that the
restaurant ain't doing too well I have
enough pressure as it is you guys are
struggling to get married and you've
been married for a long time you know
that level of pressure how did you
manage that it's been rough because we
can't do what we want to do anymore who
just can't do it
Tiffany I hate it here I he'll get mad
at me that I'm saying this but I do I
don't like it here it's not that I don't
like working I like you honestly it's
just hard
sometimes having Anthony and my parents
as partners tends to be difficult
Anthony says one thing and my parents
say another and you know sometimes they
Clash whose idea was put that pathetic
sign of the
window
me bringing some sort of customers in
right
yeah it seems everyone's in agreeance
with you know the light-hearted
decisions made by one individual what
CHF Ramsey had to say to Anthony was on
the point sitting back and just
listening and you say to yourself wow
what the hell are we doing why did we do
this are we back in out Chef Ramsey
feels one way and I feel another and at
the end of the day the name on the
awning is troianos it's not
[Music]
ramsy troianos has unfortunately become
known for one thing and one thing only
its inexpensive early bird special how
we doing that beautiful the restaurant
is only minutes away from its nightly
ritual hello how are you were you early
of
course
put you right by the
window oh my goodness
gra one thing all the family agree on is
that the food is great and Anthony well
he's certainly a confident guy now I may
be in for a treat and right now it's
time for the early
bird here we go this is this is busy yes
huh go there early aren't they 4:30 4:30
who eats there early
right
wow the decor matches the clientele drab
fuddy duddy yeah and seriously
oldfashioned I feel like I've come to
see my granny in a retirement home I
can't eat dinner at 4:30 in the
afternoon you enjoy your dinner I'm sure
what would you recommend the trano salad
is excellent It's chopped why would you
chop it people seem to love it is that
because of their teeth
maybe it must be a nightmare KN fall SP
straw
right I can't stand here
still need a few minutes I know I think
I'm ready all right what would you like
uh first thing eggplant Tower okay then
I'll have the chicken wrapped shrimp
please finally some fish what would you
recommend the Salmon's fresh it comes
with potatoes and vegetables or pasta
any past You' like but you wouldn't
serve a spaghetti with the salmon yeah
people get it all the time cuz they like
to take the past at home
usually let's go for the salmon
spaghetti B okay excellent thank you wow
two for one what up you got
it is he sleeping over
there is
he
[__] here we go right here table 10
appetizers please all right I'm very
excited to show Chef Ramsey what I can
do I feel that there will be no Faults
in what I produce for there you go wow
say eggplant Tower oh my
God one check Jeff Ramsey's appetizer
coming out you can see his face like
what is this [__] I said oh my God we're
dead that's definitely not homemade
mozzarella it's Gastly Stone Cold solid
and tasteless how are you madam how was
dinner fair fair and what have you got
in the bag what is that eggplant
Parmesan she had oh lovely when will you
have this for lunch tomorrow yeah so
you're not coming back tomorrow no not
tomorrow cuz you got dinner
there Rock briish accent thank you I
like your lipstick it's great spending
time in the company with the Golden
Girls the golden
[Laughter]
exactly Kevin bring it
out wow chicken wrap shrimp thank you
chicken and shrimp well I got the
chicken where's the
shrimp
Bingo I'm struggling with that looks
like chicken tastes like shrimp oh [__]
Joe they are solid I've never had a
shrimp that hard why would you stick a
shrimp inside a chicken it's one of his
Creations I guess okay ready Jesus yes
thank you yeah thank
you
Jesus your shrip was too hard rock hard
like a bullet okay says why would you
put shrimp inside of a chicken he says I
don't get
it all right
[Music]
when the first dis came back I was I I
was disgusted pissed off I wanted to
prove him wrong I wanted to show him my
cooking skills you know are up to par
somebody please run this [__]
F that's the bolog thank you and there's
a salmon thank you okay Christ
almighty and
dry and absolutely hideous
really sorry it's dry like really dry
okay would you mind just um not a
problem would you like another piece I
no no no no
okay your salmon was too dry he don't
want another piece he said this was
brutal here you go you want to
taste throw it
out when it came back I was just too
pissed off to even taste it I was
furious at Chef Rams saying that my food
is
[__] personally I feel that it's the
wrong opinion at this point I'm [__]
furious I'm
[Music]
furious coming up Chef Ramsey tries
everything to get through to Anthony
give me something please but he quickly
finds out that Anthony feels he's too
important to clean you're telling me now
that you don't clean that's what we have
sta for right too confident to taste
Anthony look at me taste I just didn't
want to taste it myself and too stubborn
to see the that the relationships around
him are on Shaky Ground you don't want
to hear it you don't want to hear it but
you have to this arrogant chef may be
the one that pushes Chef Ramsey over the
edge oh [__] I am out of there and out
the door we're finished we might as just
[__] burn a
[Music]
place it's only 700 p.m. early bird
customers have now left and at a time
when restaurants are usually bustling
troianos is empty all is quiet except
it's it's time for the family to hear
from Gordon let's have a chat together
yeah one thing that was absolutely
amazed with this evening is the size of
the portions when you serve an entree
you're serving a second entree with it
it's been confirmed to why we don't open
for lunch cuz you're serving the lunch
the night before so they're robbing you
however that's not the biggest problem
the food
hideous they're Leaning Tower pza what
what what's going on there with that the
egg point Tower what was wrong with it
that's not fresh mozzarella I'm really
sorry that's processed commercial
[Applause]
crap salmon did you see it when it went
back to the kitchen yes I did yeah just
because you may have the inclination
that I'm acting like a dick it was dry I
don't think you're acting like a dick I
just didn't want to taste it
myself it's hard to hear him get yelled
at but Chef if he knows what he's
talking about so he should listen to him
every time a plate comes back to my
kitchen I taste it and then the worst
dish the shrimp in the chicken where'
you go looking for the shrimp just
seemed unique now I'm even more
concerned about what you're tasting I
thought you had a better pallette than
the [__] customers in there this
evening it was hideous he can bust my
balls about my ego but you should not be
killing me over my food I know I'm a
great chef I don't think he knew what he
was talking about okay I'm out of here
it's been a tough day for
everybody good night
guys 1495
right that's not easy that slapping a
family in the face especially when
they're half a million dollars in debt
and it's tough I honestly don't know if
I can turn this
around oh dear dear dear
dear I don't know we're so frustrated
we're so worn out we're so beat up we
don't know what [__] direction we're
going anymore well obviously we have to
find the right direction because we're
drowning very quickly maybe this was a
godsent that he came
[Music]
here do you know what there's no way I
can sleep I've got to get back to the
restaurant and actually find out what
this guy's kitchen's like what's he
working with before I start putting my
plan
together as Gordon Ventures into the
kitchen the family continues their postd
meeting you need to take criticism
better me take criticism back you're
like oh these people don't know what the
[__] they're talking about you don't
want to hear it right you don't want to
hear it but you have to though like you
got to take it and be like maybe I am
doing something
wrong this is
sh what was last time this was clean
inside my
goodness look at that the floor it's
Kate to the grime oh c
[Music]
oh my
god when was the last time
this
hell oh Christ The
Mighty what
Earth the smell you know what you do
wrong take more control take more
control of these guys and I feel that
you don't if you want me to take the
control don't go check and guess me
about anything that I do
behind here oh my God [__] look at that
there that is mouse or rat droppings oh
my
God couple of hours ago I was feeling
slightly embarrassed for them slightly
concerned in a big way but now when a
chef let go of his kitchen like this it
proves he doesn't care I want to be more
involved in the business end of things
forget the business aspect and your
portion is the hosting portion
I was going back to the hotel couldn't
sleep had a look in the kitchen and I am
absolutely [__] god smacked how can
you do that when that
is say that again what is that what is
that come
here Anthony how can you cook in this
when was the last time this was cleaned
the kitchen oh we try to do it on a
daily basis I mean what have you seen
under there underneath underneath
here Joseph would you mind having a look
I don't think you've actually seen this
down there I see it look at that oh God
please Anthony talk to me give me some
form of
feedback don't [__] me give me
something please well they're asked to
do it every day the staff they what
they're asked to do with everything
we're on our ass with half a million
dollar debt and you're telling me now
that you don't even clean that's what we
have staff for right oh my
God what's this then what's that on
there the droppings they're not [__]
carway
seeds was want to wear
them couldn't imagine it was been that
bad from the surface everything looks
nice and nice when you start digging I
can't just can't believe it isn't this
your Bedrock isn't this where it's all
created from you can't create jack [__]
from here I swear to God I don't think
you give a
[__] you should be absolutely
ashamed chefery came in like a bad out
of hell and again just whip the living
crap out of me there's only so much you
you could do or say so w
Anthony give me something please oh my
God
goodness come up with an answer Anthony
although I'm [__] out of here I swear
to God I am [__] out of here I can't
take much more of this
[__] [__] it you got no
chance I am out of
[Music]
there I am out of
there
Anthony's arrogance and his refusal to
take responsibility for his kitchen have
pushed Gordon to his breaking point I am
out of
air when Gordon Ramsey walked out I said
that was it we're finished we REM you
[__] burn a place I don't know what
to do Ramsey he don't even want to help
us when I saw Chef Ramsey going out to
the street I was feeling a failure I had
to tell him how I felt and just not let
this slip through our
fingers [__] going on where do we stand
I want to get this place back why have
you given up then tell me there must be
a
reason cuz on the ambulance in there you
gave up years ago Anthony that's your
family in there
right and each and every one of them
believe in you yeah don't you feel bad
honestly don't you wake up for sleepless
nights yeah I do I do you ever had that
burden on your shoulders somebody house
not quite to this extent no I've been in
the industry for 21 [__] years
busting my balls I've made mistakes yeah
I've had failures but [__] me have I
learned from it exactly I'm trying to
learn from it are you yes I
am by that in there come on [__] come
on [__] huh I think you've had it too
easy you're one lucky [__] boy to get
hold of this restaurant
25 and I don't see that [__] level of
humbleness slightly arrogant fine but a
little bit of humility you know
that
age we able to move forward yeah jef
Ramsey taught me you need to face
reality you need to realize that maybe
you're not the only one involved in
everything time to get humble and turn
the
corner
go we've just had a chat and now we're
going to clean when that place is clean
and you see the difference you will
respect it from a completely different
level not just the kitchen the
ingredients if that's not working what
chance of we got let's do it
together oh
[__]
let's go when I seen go Ramy come back
in I said okay there's still a little
Ray
hope they clutter everything get rid of
all the food first yeah if we're going
to give this place a really good clean
at this point I'll do anything and
everything that Chef Ry does suggest is
definitely a shot of reality it's kind
of just snapping me back into
[Music]
place after a stressful night Gordon
chooses an unlik spot to introduce the
family to the first of many changes why
are we going to slaughter our own
beef this is one idea okay in order to
separate your restaurant from any other
Italian restaurant anywhere near Great
Neck what do we get from
cows make the milk the butter cheese
what do we do with milk and cheese what
do we
make mozzarella exactly exactly that
who's milked a cow before no one oh my
God
Miss glamorous Pat gloves off please
Gucci gloves off look at those gloves
look you could have prepared me a little
for this oh my God nice and gentle are
you make sure your hands are
warm yeah it's going on just try and
keep it in the
bucket this was so out there to milk
your own cow I can really say something
but I'm I'm I'm starting to get a little
excited here I never thought I'd see my
wife milk a cow she's over there playing
with the others going uh
come on Tiffany put both hands
please Tiffany oh just squeeze it go oh
my God look at this I can't believe I'm
looking a cow you've done that before no
I just I watch a lot of
West Come on Anthony put some muscle
into it she's running away you're not
blaming somebody else again are you come
on you're the
chef well
done okay on the back of last night's
scenario just bring you four together
and having some fun was great because it
looked like a family last night everyone
was in their own little turmoil so today
was really what we needed this now needs
to be pasturized we'll take it back and
we'll start making our first ever fresh
homade mozzarella ready ready yeah um
that was pathetic yeah teeths are not
your strong point
right definitely let's
go
back at the restaurant Gordon walks them
through the process of making fresh
mozzarella Anthony push all the way out
so it gets really nice and shiny perfect
there you go look that's it you've got
it I didn't know how to make fresh M we
actually had nice little Le experience
45 minutes a day Chef Ramsey's idea to
make fresh mozzarel here is definitely
putting a stamp on chanos it's something
that people are going to remember people
are going to come
[Music]
for
with a number of bookings for Friday
night Gordon decides it's an opportune
time to implement another one of his
changes okay tonight take down that
sign the early Bird's finished you don't
need it you're running up the restaurant
not a retirement home let's go now that
the early bird menu is a thing of the
past Gordon introduces pasta and
mozzarella specials to the dinner
service okay spaghetti Lobster I don't
want it flooded with a heavy coating of
tomato sauce yeah yeah over here
homemade fresh mozzarella yes with
caramelized red onions escaro bang
beautiful right two nice specials yeah
okay
good hello ladies how are you going into
dinner service I'm real nervous I got
this Buzz going on we got a lot of
things on the line here so you want a
mozzarella special yeah you can bring
them out with the appeti thank you two
more specials taste taste taste yeah
yeah I don't care if it's a [__]
sauce or a bread from you taste
yes we're looking good looking good
looking good come on the mozzarella is
fresh they actually Milk The Cow
himself Del delicious Mike spinach
ravioli lots of
ravioli eliminating our early bird
special is a lot more difficult we have
a lot more dishes to prepare for I need
the Lobster special we need to hurry up
please let's go come on go go go go go
Anthony look at me tast you [__]
taste yes I got to watch yeah I'm
probably going to make a big sign I
think Anthony needs it saying you have
to taste the food before it goes out or
I will kick his
ass okay we're coming we're coming here
we go here we go go Mike we got a s in
greeny garlic and oil coming up n and 10
right after another he's busy this guy's
getting absolutely slammed but he can
move he's definitely got talent but
there's one thing this guy hasn't done
is taste a thing from a chess point of
you how can you serve food out to the
customers and not taste anything
unacceptable beyond [__] belief now
I'm lock out while Anthony might not be
tasting his food the customers are I
think it's all right you know it's all
right and they're not impressed it's a
little
overcooked yes special T right yeah it's
dry it seems like it's been around not
D another another fucini yes please
think about it and he wants to look at
the menu so get him two
menus Anthony table 17 they're
complaining about their food saying it's
this is too dry and there's two more
gentleman said the same thing so they're
going to look at something else you got
to be [__] kidding me Anthony you got
to taste this food come on we're playing
games here we're in business over here
we're getting killed right now falling
behind big time it's an hour into dinner
service and a kitchen that is not used
to being busy is starting to crumble all
right it's 25 night by the time we go I
got to go
where's my
potatoes Fu you got to be kidding
me Anthony was definitely getting his
ass kicked tonight please get it out
come on the food was taking too long
people were scrambling because they were
trying to rush go go go go hurry up oh
[__] something's
burning
[Applause]
fire oh my God that's not good Jo
Anthony oh
[__] with the kitchen already running
behind Michael's burnt entree has
brought the dinner service to a grinding
halt Anthony come on come on come on
come
on oh my God up
up Jesus
Christ we'll regroup here we'll regroup
okay on a night filled with more
setbacks than successes Anthony is
trying to salvage the evening by
pleasing the remaining
customers it's like nothing I'm
ashamed of uh myself and I didn't think
it was as bad as the clientele found it
to be you know could be I guess blinders
that I was wearing you know how [__]
pissed I am they think tonight was a
disaster you know it's depressing and I
know we have to change things I just
don't know what to do oh my God coming
out too slow can I have S please with
the line what's the L please leave me
alone please I'm
begging Tiffany and I's relationship has
been Rocky the stress that we've been
through over the past 3 years has
definitely Pro to be the breaking point
if the restaurant went to fail maybe we
don't move on maybe that's the end of
our road my
God okay tonight didn't go by without
its
problems Anthony from the first plate
that left your kitchen to the last plate
you didn't taste a [__]
thing you can't be that [__]
arrogant it was a travesty that is your
[__] job and the minute you don't do
that don't call yourself a chef I never
really tasted things beforehand never
thought it was necessary I guess that
just comes with the cocky and the
arrogance of me you have got to taste if
you're not tasting it what the customer
experiencing you know Anthony should be
tasting his food he should know why the
clientele is complaining it's just
hurting my business and it's hurting my
family tomorrow we have to be different
Anthony it separates you from being
average to something quite
special if you thought tonight was busy
hey God help you because we are
launching this Resturant tomorrow I know
it's late get some sleep a big day
tomorrow see you in the morning good
night I feel like it can't get any worse
than it is now hopefully tomorrow is
going to be a new beginning for
[Music]
everybody in preparation for the
relaunch Gordon's team worked through
the night updating trobiano's stagi
interior good morning morning right big
day today bring launch day a lot of
changes you didn't like this place place
when I first arrived yeah you didn't
like the decor didn't like the lighting
and it was Bland are you ready for a
change yes let's
go come through come through out with
the old in with the new oh my God holy
[__] it's warm yes I couldn't believe
what I seen I was definitely in the
wrong place I was dreaming everything
was unbelievable the chairs the the
table PS the boots I mean everywhere you
look was beautiful oh look at this
that's Italy on the yes you're running
an Italian restaurant so we're going to
have some authentic Italian pictures on
the wall I used to hate this place I
used to hate coming in here but now with
a new Decor everything just goes really
well together so everything is just
perfect it's romantic it's warm and more
importantly it's sexy this is great look
at this that is a mozzarella bar wow
that's awesome are you happy happy good
good man good
man come here no I'm happy I'm not cry
oh no no no no I just can't believe it I
can't it's more than I've ever ever
expected it's beautiful it's a total
fresh start you know we we're going to
take from today and just keep moving
forward okay good the menu absolutely
crucial we've condensed it and it's
simple and rustic oh my God okay no more
salmon and bolog sauce it's authentic
portions have been trimmed and they're
sensible portions he showed us the menu
it was downsized the prices were better
it's beautiful it's all in place now
tonight is where it's got to work I'm a
little nervous for Anthony this is where
he has to show what he's made of so
hopefully he can get that
done coming up with relaunch upon them
troianos is finally put to the test the
editor and chief of the Bon of te
magazine they want to join us for dinner
oh my God this could be a great
opportunity for troianos or could be the
final nail in the CL can Anthony and the
staff rise to the occasion the most
important Roto you've made in your
[__] life or will they crack under
the pressure what's the matter this was
cold in the middle just when it was
going perfectly well the [__] soul
comes back and at the end of service a
shocking surprise that will change this
family for years to come I was shocked I
never expected this in a million
years in preparation for the big
relaunch Gordon introduces the staff to
the new dishes gone are the shrimp and
the chicken and the dried out salmon in
their place authentic Italian dishes the
Sal nicy roasted potatoes rosme garlic
salmon the riy steak and the lamb Ragu
homemade mozzarella we've got hundreds
of balls of fresh mozzarella right have
a taste wow this is good tasty salad y
That's good oh my God everything is so
delicious okay guys it is going to be a
very important night and it is
absolutely crucial we stay together on
it uh one more thing I had a phone call
from the editor and chief of the bonab
magazine they want to join us for dinner
oh my God I'm very nervous about tonight
you know when he just told us about the
critic coming that scares the hell out
of me this is a real chance to put this
place on the map just under 6 million
people read that magazine per month
tonight I have to make sure Anthony
stays on the right track with his
cooking with his tasting of the food
everything is on the line this could be
a great opportunity for troianos or
could be the final nail in the
[Music]
C how are you very welome Hi how are you
I'm Joe how you doing you going oh it
looks nice looks just like a Manhattan T
and I want to take I just wanted to tell
you we're trying something new we have a
Mella bar here we go let's go so they
got one each so six slices there six
slices on
there excellent see Bang Yeah 30 seconds
$80 off you go got there's one for you
and one for you what this is this is
delicious though another one yeah for
four can't believe how well this is gone
this is unbelievable it's extraordinary
fill up on the appetizer right right
follow him behind Chicken F you got one
Ragu coming up you're tasting the food
me one please tell me you taste it taste
the [__] stuff
man it's very important to keep the
standard sign we have to impress a lot
of people we got a lot of things on the
line here no I want got to make sure
they're tasting the [__] I got to watch
them now with troiano was busier than it
has been in years the pressure is now on
Anthony to keep up with the orders but
his staff must come through for him as
well Kevin table four I have no idea
what that is bro oh yeah with vegetables
sorry Danny I have 26s does not make
sense buddy what's going on here the way
staff here is killing me Anthony you
can't read the [__] thing give it
back to him yeah yes here take them
rewrite it right here quick Kevin got to
get these tickets sorted otherwise
you're going to get [__] in 15 minutes
yeah yes sir yes while an then he gets
the staff in line are they finished with
it so is it fired right away I need to
know Joe scans the dining room looking
for the bone Appetit table any sign of B
yeah good eyes open yeah Tony stop
pushing out these Entre now you're on
top of it now stay on top of it yeah how
we goinging baby
done yeah than okay all right
enjoy wow now why can't I make fish like
this
please watch that you have potential you
have potential critic yes this and this
very nice go go go go go go
go
yes is it really I'm so sorry okay no
problem Excuse me yes what's the matter
this is cold in the middle what table is
that a
10 a
[__] hey just when it was going
perfectly well a [__] so comes back
when just came back the only thing that
was running through my head was whether
it was the bone up PE te
table the traditional stuff is very good
yeah chicken parmesan very good we want
all the pastas the pork chops lamb to
give everybody a little taste you wanted
one of each uhh okay thank you okay no
problem you're welcome how' you know
it's them uh they ordered everything on
the menu they're asking questions
they're asking questions they're
ordering a lot of wine
that is definitely a food critic Anthony
Table 9 there six people one of them I
think is the critic step it up yeah yes
bounce back come on let's go okay we're
going to do Table 9 a very very very
important table all right here we go 3
minutes on the pasta Tony looking good
looking good Anthony yeah watch at Roto
yes yes chef yes hey the most important
Roto you've made in your [__] life
look at that huh beautiful Table 9 Roto
and Ragu I need a second bus boy please
quickly nine please wow that looks
greatti everything's on the line tonight
if we don't make it then you know it's
just going to be a
[Music]
disaster that's lovely it's the relaunch
dinner and Tiffany has just delivered
Entre to the editor and chief of bone
Appetit now all the family can do is
hope I'm very nervous about the critics
I really do think that my business is at
stake tonight see they're going to make
us or break us how it tastes to The Fish
Victoria the fish and the chicken are
really winners is not overcooked no it
was nicely cooked good asking lots of
questions and more importantly they're
passing food Round which is a great sign
not happy with it you don't pass it how
is the bass you like it yeah very good
right yes that was a nice recommendation
good thank you
any complaints no no complaints at all
it's great that they're here you know
that fantastic amazing it's a dream
beautiful beautiful awesome I was at an
all-time high with Bor Petit knowing
that if this positive review comes out
that it's going to put troianos above
and beyond where we ever imagined with a
wealth of satisfied customers and a good
response from bonea petite troiano's
relaunch is a success but Chef Ramsey
knew that Anthony still had some
unfinished business the restant on his
way tonight proved that but there's one
more
thing what is
this you beautiful make an honest woman
of
her I'm
shaking this is unbelievable this is
coming from you yeah to us You'
forgotten about it and if there's one
thing that's missing it's that and I
know personally how long you've been
putting it off because of the pressure
from the restaurant that is going to put
an into it okay yeah
speechless thank you get up there stand
strong tiffan is a great girl she's put
up with me for the past 3 years there
was no better time than tonight to go
ahead with this and ladies and gentlemen
I'd like to introduce you to our Chef
Patron Anthony
Tano
I just want to thank everyone for coming
here um you can see we come a long way
thanks to uh Chef Ramsey here and we've
moved in such a positive direction that
there's just one thing in my life
that it hasn't been official
Tiffany will you marry
me woohoo
[Music]
excellent I was shocked that Anthony
proposed to me in front of everybody it
was just incredible I never expected
this in a million years I can't believe
this it totally touched me to see
Anthony propose a Tiffany and I know
this is what he's wanted it's just
unbelievable it's a dream come true you
better make my daughter happy what do
you mean I'll [__] kick your ass I
have one more surprise for both of you
I've arranged for both of you to get
married married
[Applause]
[Music]
tonight we were just totally shocked
with all the excitement of everything
else going on to top it off with a
wedding come
on I thought I was going to
die oh my God this is crazy I love
Anthony I've been waiting for this for 6
years we have a new life to start so
everything should just fall into place
now
[Applause]
[Music]
Tiffany and Anthony have come together
to Proclaim their Undying Love through
the celebration of their
marriage I am filled with so many
emotions it was an amazing night that
law just unbelievable there's no other
word to describe all of this really um
ladies and gentlemen I just like to say
this family have been a pleasure to work
with Chef ramsley did definitely save
our lives you got to be kidding me if he
didn't come here 6 months from now we'
probably been close I'm grateful my
family's grateful and I hope this is a
new beginning for all of
us wow amazing I've seen many a dream
turned into a nightmare tonight a
nightmare turned into a beautiful
[Music]
dream